how long ago was that epic
beef with jake paul that was like
almost two years ago now i think maybe
longer maybe three years yeah maybe
three years
that was uh
that was something else huh it was
pretty wild
and
so just and now he can beat the [ __ ] out
of me i mean he broke it back then too
right like uh i mean it wasn't anything
terribly aggressive that you had done
right like you just sort of made a
reaction video to his rapping and called
it cringy and like
like
it and so then
he shows up just bum rushes you on like
some set that you were working on and
like really aggro and like ah come on
come on
yeah it was supposed to be like a joke
like the guy that
right
yeah he was like thought that he'd be
kind of like in on the joke right and
then he came in he like used it as an
opportunity like film it himself
right and uh yeah the whole thing felt
just really weird i was like really
uncomfortable like afterwards i was like
man i feel like i don't know what the
[ __ ] just happened right
it was really bizarre i think i read
that i think it read that way that like
when you saw him you were like oh hey
man i'm [ __ ] cool dude like like you
know you could tell that there was
nothing
like there's no real like malice or
animosity on your part right yeah and he
came with this crazy energy
um and
what was most odd i think to me was that
it was jake himself who put out the
video
that just felt like awkward and weird
yeah and kind of like you you looked
like
uh
he kind of felt like he put out a video
that made you look good
yeah
i don't know the whole situation was so
so bizarre
plus i had a fresh cut
i just got a fresh haircut i looked
incredible
did that change your uh
your approach to
internet bullying
yeah i started bullying in a different
way after that
i think you know i think like you know
sometimes i go back and i watch those
old videos
like that's cringes and stuff like that
that we used to do
the ones that he was pissed about i mean
i don't even know if he was pissed at
the one that we did about him he
probably was but i go back and watch
those and sometimes i'm like man we did
go really [ __ ] hard but it's like
it's a young dude thing you know you
mid-20s you think you're the [ __ ] man
can't do any wrong and then you get to
30 and you're like i just like you know
i just want everybody to like me yeah
and it's just like i just i'm getting
older now and it's like you know as
cliche as it sounds it's like negativity
doesn't really breed
anything like the ceiling is pretty low
wow so like now it's like we we do
you know we still are trying to remain
edgy and like we're comedians so we you
know like to make fun of [ __ ] but um
in a little bit of a lighter-hearted way
i guess i don't know it's called stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and if you
go on amazon and type in stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're
ranked number 30 on all of amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on amazon and buy stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude